50 fucking seconds of celestially themed
logos
everyone was warned but no one listens
so we will keep making whether disaster
films until you listen congress also
narration and also also blatant
exposition ok movie are you just gonna
write this for us
well there later be some asshole
graduating from the Prometheus school
running away from things while eating an
apple and not getting a lap dance a rise
in temperature ocean patterns changed
and ice caps melted leading to what I
can only assume is an inconvenient geo
storm floods and droughts sounds like we
just need to take the floods where there
are droughts and routes where there are
floods then they'll cancel each other
out
you're welcome planet rip East whoever
swallowed lower Manhattan but we could
only provide this found footage style
reenactment because Dean Devlin's got to
spend the majority of his Geo storm
budget on the Geo storm and Gerard
Butler's half beard oil I Hate Waste
you're 2 million people in Madrid in
just one day
wait did 2 million people not know how
hot it was outside or did this heatwave
arrived suddenly out of nowhere like a
shark attack the world came together as
one and had no idea that geo storm was
part of the bill and ted's expanded
universe here was God gave rock'n'roll
to you broadcast to the universe I
always got the timelines confused it
gave the satellite net attacked in
clinic but we all came to call it Dutch
boy after the story of the child who
floods a dam with his finger someone
pitch Sean Connery's character sir
August a winter from the 1998 Avengers
movie but it was discovered in 2019 that
that movie was even more obscure than
the Hans Brinker novels so Dutch boy 1
also this is apparently a sophisticated
yada-yada net that does blah blah blah
the pearls the weather with a dumpling
series of thingamabobs so how is that
equivalent to sticking your finger in a
dike it was built by a team led by one
man and that man's name was geo storm
tornado zap blizzard zap you know what
would have made a way more awesome movie
the sky creating Dutch boy in showing us
his invention zapping tornados and
blizzards but sure let's make this about
when Dutch boys go wrong and may the
record reflect that he was nearly one
hour late and why does it matter
nobody knows no one will ever speak of
it again then there was the incident
where you punched a federal inspector in
the face I hate how this movie begins
for a variety of reasons and hearing
about what a dick Jake is before we even
get to the amaze
part of his invention is one and despite
the fact that I believe our government
is useless I find it hard to believe
they'd be such hard asses - the guy who
saved the world the worst series of
storms building in Southeast Asia and in
North Atlantic that would have killed
tens of thousands of people that sounds
low considering that heat waves were
killing two million people in Madrid
alone okay where do you get that little
brother huh Jake helpfully verbally
identifies max as his little brother
within the first minute of dialogue
because this is a stupid action movie
that doesn't have time for subtlety is
for arthouse movies like Avengers
infinity war I told ya this had the
co-wallow is that all you told him
because how to talk to senators and
don't insult the Senators might have
been a good conversation to have if they
can control the weather so expertly why
are there even wide swaths of desert
anymore
are there still water shortages in
Africa are there no storms at all these
movie interested in explaining any of
this we find out later that this was
some sort of malfunction on dutchboy
that caused this but again much like the
heatwave that killed two million people
in Madrid I've got to wonder how this
happened so quickly that people are
frozen instantly it's not even anyone
running or looking up to the sky because
it happened that fast and what about the
surrounding heat how does the satellite
block the Sun from hitting the spot no I
no need to check on these guys to see if
there's any sign of life even though
this is clearly a freaking Amelie you
and recon team found it mr. president
I'm convinced that at this stage in his
career Andy Garcia is only agreeing to
roles that feature less than five total
minutes of screen time with this many
people in the loop I'm not sure how long
it's going to keep ah Christoph also
seriously these two acting legends
finally share a movie and it's king geo
storm I will not be the president that
hands over damaged goods Andy Garcia is
the president that we deserve but he's
not the one we need right now seventeen
countries had teams working on dutchboy
they all reported to him nobody knows
what's under the hood better than half
manipulates position no one will be
seated during the International Space
Station replaces the Afghanistan
satellite scene this Bulls Starship
Troopers taught me anything it was that
in the future there would be unisex
locker rooms
I feel so deceived and I thought I told
you not to talk to strangers even at 13
Hannah can clearly understand how
fucking hokey this dialogue is
government authority figure has to track
down the one person who can do the job
but he's living in a shack in Florida
and working on a vintage car cliche
dutchboy was all you ever gave a damn
about the perils of calling your movie
tech dutchboy is that it requires actors
to repeatedly say dutch-born okay
well then what are you doing living out
here hmm damn that's a convenient ass
rocket launch hang on not only is this
but this workstation is in what has to
be one of the most technologically
advanced buildings in the world and they
still use landlines that look like
they're from 1996 yeah I do much
parenting oh boy a bad father looks like
you've got some emmerich in my devlin of
course it's very possible the bad father
thing was always Devlin but I just want
to blame roland emmerich for everything
think of it like I'm going on a vacation
for a week or two this movie's discount
interstellar it's the same problem Earth
has the environment and a really smart
little girls dad has to go into space to
make it all better I hope we get to see
crying Gerard Butler later in the not so
distant future next Sunday ad the US has
enough money in 430 launching pads with
their own dedicated rocket at what point
does any country need this many rockets
on call even if they have a complex
weather controlling gadget in space have
a safe trip sir an holy Jake's the only
asshole flying in the ship couldn't they
have scheduled this one the other rocket
was flying to space a minute ago or is
this just a luxury you can afford when
you have 117 rockets lying around
oh yeah this reminds me this Jake's body
even ready to go to space after three
years of beer-swilling and bad parenting
okay up until now the effects have been
surprisingly passable but the shot looks
like it belongs on a Saturday morning
cartoon show on the CW look at you girl
sure it sounds all cool coming out of
the drawer but Lou's mouth but I get
slapped with a restraining order when I
say this to my college girlfriend well I
thought she was sleeping oh maybe I need
to speak to your chief scientists about
the fine art of giving a shit I'm the
chief scientist I've been promoted to
here ago here's bad movie logic for you
Jake is approached by his brother max to
go back to the place he was fired from
before we know it he's on a ship by
himself flying to that place and now
he's talking to the chief scientist but
was never briefed on what's changed or
who's in charge oh of course
an American actually my brother and I
were born in the UK this line was
definitely inserted to explain Gerard
Butler's dialect in this movie after it
was screened okay maybe not definitely
but you would totally believe that
wouldn't you you are
this is mr. Jake Lawson and he might be
one of the most famous men in the world
after he saved it so it's really strange
that people like you who work on Dutch
boy you don't know who he is
max jumps into bed unshaven with rumpled
hair and a wrinkled t-shirt Sarah is
posing perfectly on the bed with her
nightgown and cleavage just so and not a
hair out of place but they both equally
want to fuck right now far worse and the
very thing we're trying to prevent wait
what was that a Geo storm aha are all
those credits also how the fuck would
max have never heard about this
possibility
he runs the goddamn department that
handles the POTUS called a last minute
press parade why you can't stay despite
getting the warning from Chang seeing
the destruction on TV and being informed
of an emergency meeting called by the
president max is still in full-on
flirtation mode proving once again that
the power of boners is greater than the
power of Geo storms that's my fave
actually I call it a rock and roll aah I
prefer to call it NIMS island or the
ugly truth since we're obviously just
calling things by Gerard Butler movie
titles now it looks like bad servo
relayer drunk sailor man for a movie
about a catastrophic weather event there
is a lot of computer porn tell no one
yeah especially since I'm brazenly
waving my little secret access thingy
and having this discussion in a
completely open environment Oh whew with
this hologram screen how is this better
hey guys I want a machine that controls
the weather around the world and also I
want to join hallway filling hologram
screen so that I can talk to earth while
looking at a blurry glittery image
actually you'll be reporting to max here
good luck
so what was the purpose of this urgent
call just to tell Jake that his brothers
in charge how does he not already know
this just because he wanted it to be
someone else just one week after mom and
dad died you got arrested for fighting
expositional arguing but if you ever
authorize anything without my approval
we on the next shuttle nine and we'll
all be dead because of Geo storm but I
will have taught you a goddamn listen do
you movie if you're gonna show me that
the satellite is this big and it's about
to ram into these people in this shot
don't tell me it's this far away in the
next shop did this walk away double in
size between cuts granted I've never
spaced before but it is a vacuum right
after the first panel blew shouldn't
this dude have been sucked out of that
opening or does space have a dramatic
sense of timing it was terrific in 2001
a Space Odyssey
step across the gravity threshold why
does the spacewalk require the two most
important people in the dutchboy
operation I can't this be some
designated maintenance people especially
since the world has so much money to run
this shuttle people back and forth daily
let's just get the panels and see what's
on those drives I'm stating the exact
mission that you just told us 30 seconds
ago in case anyone has that memento
condition in the theater also it's
absolutely totally fucking amazing that
no one's bothered to get this panel
until now this happened a week ago
Jake's known for some time that
someone's sabotaging everything on
dutchboy
he suspected it before he boarded
got confirmation from his brother and
got first-hand experience with it when
the satellite went haywire at this point
I don't know why he trusts anyone
and every mission should be taken with
the idea that someone doesn't want him
to figure out what the evil plan is and
I think they were gone for the terror of
gravity but ended up with a comedy at
The Three Stooges in orbit why didn't
you tell them about the drive because
someone just tried to kill me yeah but
why did you tell her about it oh it's
because she's pretty she can't be evil
got it
you've been locked out what the hell
does this movie want to be sci-fi
thriller apocalyptic effects fest a
geopolitical whodunit make up your
goddamn mind movie just like Jim
Sturgess is just using this movie as an
excuse to try out different hairstyles
oh come on
this guy's been tracking Channing the
whole time from Hong Kong to Washington
he could have killed this dude in so
many other ways and privately this is
agent Wilson yes I know right now that
sir I have to identify herself as an
agent can't you just call 9-1-1 abbie
cornish t1000 of course dad was a
government spy his whole life caught me
red-handed it really is incredible to
hear Gerard Butler's American and
Scottish accents battle each other in
real time his cell phone number is the
key even if I allow Jake memorizing this
fake phishing story down to the precise
word so that his brother could crack it
using their dad's old cell phone number
I find it a little hard to believe that
the software they're using could figure
out stuff like red-handed or no one
being one word and keeping the count
right for easy to cipher and even if I'm
wrong about that then I will bring up a
real nitpick how this video is in no way
how Gerard Butler performed it in the
movie a minute ago so I'm sending
something about this god damn it sure
don't tell you're naturally suspicious
Secret Service girlfriend that you're
bringing a stranger to the house tonight
that can't ever end badly
I can explain everything what about that
statement is pervy
I mean if he'd said I was gonna well
we're in your my own gonna have the who
was gonna off the now that would be
perfect and you know that is bigger than
you you know shut up indeed shut up it
is you and me the easiest way to know is
to take the you and out of the sentence
and see if it holds up look being a
grammar nazi can be bad but being an
incorrect grammar nazi and I'm not
saying this because the actress is
German either so get that out of your
head
whoever did that killed my mother
and what makes you think it is not me
these are things completely innocent
people with guns say bingo looks more
like a dildo to me but I get those words
confused sometimes too it really gets
them riled up on Tuesday nights at the
assisted living center Geno storm why
can't anything we've ever seen have you
seen other geo storms sure no one in the
Secret Service is gonna care if you
leave your post with the president in
sight to go talk to someone everyone
knows is your boyfriend I've got this
Sara keeping the president safe doesn't
require a team effort
Jake these is to steal the kill codes
from Palma at least 70% of this movie is
people imploring other people to do
things to even other people Jesus people
just yelled geo storm and everyone will
understand I can still the convoys in
the shower awesome
I was wondering if we'd make it through
this slog without at least a little Andy
Garcia skin
we've lost ball control the Tokyo
satellite because it's the one city that
roland emmerich hasn't destroyed on film
and Dean Devlin has got to get his nut
on without using sloppy seconds max I
didn't know you were coming to the
convention I know max is high-level
State Department but this is Air Force
One and he's not on the manifest did
they let unexpected employees just tag
along on an impromptu basis I got if
there's not a helicopter shot of the
Christ the Redeemer statue getting blow
the fuck up in the scene I'm gonna ping
riot just under a minute ago we already
saw ice crashing into the beaches of Rio
so why is it still only this far inland
when we go back to it Dominic Toretto
should be frozen solid racing for pink
slips against a gang leader by now he
gets frozen a quarter-mile at a time man
I love how they set up this one hot
chick is the one person we should care
about during this Rio Country tropical
freeze like literally the only character
trait that she has is that she's in a
bikini and she's hot and we saw her
boyfriend get frozen a minute ago so
we're planning moving in on that later
well damn we had a good streak there but
there goes HBM again I know what you're
saying but Jeremy this is a
malfunctioning weather satellite and I
say that's what I call HBO when it's not
playing new episodes of Game of Thrones
god damn it
one hour 30 minutes unfortunately no one
watching this movie was given the same
warning and many tens of people died
this is supposed to be a sophisticated
system right like shouldn't it be giving
latitude and longitude coordinates
instead of the metropolitan city name
it's gonna hit only within the city
limits of Orlando next I know everything
about you your father's death why'd you
lie to me
well importantly why didn't you say
anything about it until now I gotta tell
you something
max violates Mubi rule 182 which is
never share info with that Harris when
you need someone you can trust and I
need the president has kill God we're
gonna shut down boy down now apparently
the only character trait listed for max
was constantly out of breath also if max
trusts Jackson Pollock why doesn't he
immediately tell him about the impending
storm that's headed directly toward them
president is a kill call biometric wait
they entrusted the entirety of the
global weather regulation to one person
I mean I know they pretty much do that
for nukes this seems like even more of a
stupid plan also this seems like a very
sensitive discussion to be having in the
middle of a crowded convention hall with
dozens of civilians and pres hanging
around thanks an important character who
shouts thinks I thought there might be a
way to control the satellites without
the station but you've set me straight
where's Duncan he's the only one with
enough programming expertise to override
the commands done Oh like why you didn't
write out a list of the most obvious
suspects and this whole thing is beyond
me gonna figure this out in like a
couple hours probably pay this guy has
no problem killing pools left and right
but now at this critical moment sure why
not lay out your motivations before
capping Olympus has fallen here also
earlier they ruled out the French guy
because Jake figured he'd have been dead
already if it was him so why is that not
true for the British guy oh wait I
remember this in A Tale of Two Cities
somewhere something about French guys
kill you instantly British guys let you
live and tell you the plan before they
attempt to kill you
I think Charles Darnay says that are you
a little bit curious to watch the world
but you know I've heard a lot of Michael
Caine impressions and this is the worst
one yet even though the satellite is
blowing up and the Geo storm is imminent
and the world is in peril and president
Garcia's in the middle of a dope speech
at the DNC we've got time for an orbital
fistfight
and try and tell you anything else man
this is some ham-handed from deck I'm
here bringing up Chang's name
he has max all to himself and all he's
got to do is get him behind closed doors
and end this motherfucker but instead he
gives away that he's the bad guy as if
being Ed Harris wasn't enough we're
leaving her post again how is Sarah not
fired already kidnapped the president
that sounds reasonable well it's the
only move we've got between the
whispered breathless dialogue and the
bonkers political abduction strategy you
could easily convince me this was an
episode of 24 and sure seemed like a
good idea but Sarah took out at least
four good lighting guys wait how did
Jake catch up to the entire crew he
ordered evac like 10 minutes ago and had
the confrontation the fistfight with
anonymous British guy number one so he
should be way behind everyone I'm sorry
you need to come with me I swear to God
that I've seen abbie cornish actually
act but the effects of Geo store are
apparently far too strong and it's like
those little wooden lift gates don't do
anything to deter rogue agents that
kidnap the president suddenly the Koch
brothers just got unexpected
simultaneous erections god dammit does
every one of these disaster movies have
to have a lost dog sub sub sub plot it's
like we care if the one dog gets saved
but we forget about the millions already
dead from this by the way I'm lumping in
all the in case you confused it with
sins here because this movie has so many
it's worse than a Bourne movie but in
case you confused with Moscow New
Hampshire and ten sends more from me
please
having my brother and I lead the
investigation was a setup from the start
think about he hired us to fail I hire
anybody except people he could control
he'd put a mole on dutchboy and while
that sounds dirty that's what he did he
had people inside the Secret Service
working for why not hire Jim Joe Bob
Benedict Darrell the guy with a degree
in science from State College this is a
super speaking plan as if the John
Cusack drives a car through buildings
while avoiding crashing over past the
scene in 2012 wasn't enough
Dean Devlin reaches down deep and works
up the courage to do a miniature version
for this movie we need to go we haven't
heard from him in hours I trust him who
gives it about trusting him the man
might be dead or unconscious or having
sex with heavy kornish all these things
would prevent him from making the call
after answered it manual yet
the mainframe I mean it's not my type of
dirty talk but whatever gets you going
I'll be the sole survivor ready to be
sworn in as the next president of the
United States I'm just wondering what
was Dec UM's planned before max told him
he knew something was up I guess he was
just gonna slip out of the arena at the
right time but why wasn't he already
gone before that the storm began well
before Deckman confronted max about
lying about why he came to Orlando and
not long after that the arena exploded
fine
I mean I know it's a Geo storm and
everything but if this storm does blow
over wouldn't there be an investigation
into the massive rocket launcher attack
that ultimately killed the president
wouldn't there be at least an Oliver
Stone movie about it because I'm the
goddamn President of the United States
of America
well that and he had to people go
absolutely rogue and kidnap him away
from danger but yeah president America
you're done village what where did all
these assholes come from and even though
this is the president in all shouldn't
all the rescue personnel be helping the
entire city over Orlando didn't the fool
Moxley center blow up with all the
Democrats I'm turning the clock back to
1945 when America was a shining city on
a hill mega you know what my brother
would say what yeah he was a dick but we
only realized he was a dick 17 minutes
ago
this punch hasn't earned this isn't
something that's been building the whole
movie oh yeah even though the bad guy
was already caught we've got several
more minutes of Geo storming since the
movie neglected the Geo storm for most
of its runtime the day after tomorrow a
3d Tomorrow Never Dies Station
self-destruct can't be reversed well it
can't look the only guy who could
override it we got sucked into a vacuum
of space we really should have hired
more IT guys why does some of the
satellites send out storms but some of
them get all stark Hillary I know all
that talk about the manual insertion
into the mainframe got you revved up
before but now it's not the time what
are you doing I told you yeah sure but
what have you been doing the whole time
as soon as the last shuttle left you
could have been like Here I am bitch but
instead you hung around doing nothing
until springing your surprise at the
last minute it should come as no
surprise but this countdown clock is
total bull anyone who relies on this
asshole is an asshole yes you look you
can show all these explosions around the
Santaland all you want but if Jay can do
to escape this then you are lying so
that's it we done geo storming jeez I
never knew how much I'd miss it
that's racist wait even the flooding
water decided get let's not flood this
city anymore let's go home because
that's what flooding water does it's
tough but fair on the station hey why is
it still storming in Atlanta
I thought the storms were over even the
Geo kind you can't undo the past they
set up this girl to be more than a
bookend narrator and daughter who's
worried about her dad the whole movie
but they didn't pity what a waste and
she's right we can't undo the past
[Music]
everyone was warned but no one listened
excuse me I'm not asking for your input
your commander must cross that field put
his head between his legs and catch his
own arse
[Music]
trust no one
ground control to Major Tom
houston we have a problem